the first three episodes I sort of
looked like a monster but I it's funny
cuz my parents binge watched it they
called it like I'm gonna be loved the
show's like what did you think I seem
like they're like they nailed your ass
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the closet I'm
Jen that's Nikki in the closet is a
showroom we talk about things that are
fun and important to you America and how
international are we yeah okay and
people in the world also we should
sidebar so this closet that were in
today is a storage closet as evidenced
by all the cleaning supplies behind
Nikki said yeah we're just prepared for
whatever gem spills today anyway today
the topic of the show is following your
dreams to talk about that we have a good
friend of the show her name is a
responder and she's gonna come sidle on
in to the closet right now please Arisa
welcome welcome welcome vital sidle
sidle come on in I'm welcome to the
closet hi
I'm Maurice tell us a little about
yourself I've been modeling for 12 years
I'm on a show called strut on oxygen the
first all trans cast show on television
more olive color which is really fun
identify as she I'm a transgender female
not a regular female I'm irregular no
I'm kidding hahaha you're talking a
little bit about dreams would you say
that you are following your dreams all
of my dreams have come true so far I can
comfortably say I've wanted to be a
model like a supermodel since I was 14
recently I got my first cover and I can
cover up Spiegel which is 111 years old
and their first trans model ever to be
on the cover how did you get from being
a kid to where you are now
it's a long road I started modeling at
17 there's a male model and then uh I
did catalog work like small fashion
shows you gotta start somewhere kids
sorry I'm sorry there's no elevator to
success you got to take the stairs like
people I've been asked by reporters are
like what are you surprised at this
whole transgender movement I'm like hell
yeah I've been openly trans for 12 years
like of course I'm shocked because I
wasn't it wasn't so trendy or cooler
accepted even 5 years ago so to see this
wave of acceptance and people just being
super nice and understanding that we're
people and we have dreams and hopes and
lives you know I'm going to Trader Joe's
right after this he
so was there ever a time where you were
like I can't do it or like this every
day
haha you're always gonna go through this
things but that's why you have to be so
grateful for your support system because
there's people you can call you can call
your best friends I'll call your mother
and then they remind you why you started
my biggest thing I've advice would be to
live a life of gratitude like never take
for granted any of your opportunities or
connections or just the people that you
surround yourself with and be thankful
for all of them and just show them how
grateful you are because it always comes
back around and so my Karma's just come
back full force wise I just keep waiting
so we like to play little games to close
things out I do silly little things what
are some tips for modeling if you're a
drinker like me they're gonna want to
suck in your cheeks to give yourself a
little bit extra definition on your
cheekbone and it gives it makes your
teeth pop and it makes your lip pout I
called the Victoria Beckham phase yeah
and I usually bring up a hand to give
your jaw a little more definitions and
they need to Tory back up they see you
ready let your mouth go I mean that
Vittori to mess them well no no I hadn't
met David Beckham oh yeah yeah he bought
us drinks he was so nice I said I
absolutely love your wife and he was
like oh let's get them around a drink
because I didn't say oh my god you're
David Beckham I was like I love your
wife I read her book twice look I love
her
alright oh that's far out uh Maurice
thank you so much for being on the show
thank you for having me come that way
bye bye guys effects it this way cause
it's bad don't think walls Oh closet
we're making dreams come true
[Music]